lead-up to this summit you actually
tweeted out if you were given the great
city of Moscow for retribution for all
the sins etc of Russia the media would
be asking why you didn't get
saint-petersburg as well I said that I
said if I got Moscow as a as part of a
deal they said here's Moscow please
please pardon us that soccer ball was
really very nice I have to say it was
very nice you know they did a great job
in in running that but it is true you
know I said if I got Moscow they'd won
Saint Petersburg where they had one more
so the media was a very unfair I never
thought this was one I said this is
foolproof
I raised 44 billion and the Secretary of
General said he raised 44 billion and
was only president job because I said
leather wise we're gonna have to start
thinking about our relationship to NATO
I also said this NATO is wonderful but
it helps Europe a lot more than it helps
us and yet we're paying for 90 percent
of it so I was amazed that the most of
the meeting you didn't and some others
didn't but much of the media said that I
was tough very tough and nasty to
foreign leaders and I really wasn't at
all but I did say you have to pay up we
talked about Europe as a foe you talked
about Vladimir Putin as a foe and you
clarified that means a competitor
similarly the media's upset you say an
enemy of the people are you really
saying that they're not doing their job
and well I say enemy of the people I'm
talking about all the media I'm talking
about there is a big percentage of media
when you look at CNN how false their
reports are when you look at NBC and
some of the others when you read the New
York Times it's just story after story
after story that's just a negative spin
and we're doing great things we have the
greatest economy in the history of our
country we have the best unemployment
numbers in the history of our country
best african-american unemployment
numbers in history Hispanic numbers in
history women's numbers in history
states have records 14 straights I
didn't know that low unemployment
surprised it's only 14 actually that's a
disappointing number
the keep working hard I think it'll get
there but the more amazing thing too is
we have more jobs available than we
actually have people on unemployment
what up
in the labor participation rate and the
country has never been higher first time
let me go back because everybody in the
media is so focused on this in 2014 in
the Washington Times Devin unas said
with a certainty that Russia would try
to impact the 2016 elections Barack
Obama in the month before the 2016
elections and I will read and I will
quote no serious per person out there
would suggest that somehow you could
even rig America's elections no evidence
that it has happened in the past which
is not true and number two or that it
could happen in this election and I
invite mr. Trump to stop whining and to
go out there and try and get votes he
would said that two weeks before the
election well he thought Hillary Clinton
was going to win and he didn't want to
do anything to disturb it and you know
frankly when I won he said this is the
biggest deal but before I won he said
this is nothing and it can't happen it's
a very dishonest deal and you know you
have to find out who did Peter struck
report to because it was Comey and it
was McCain but it was also probably
Obama if you think that Obama didn't
know what was going when you watch and I
said it today with President Putin when
you watch Peter Struck's
performance the lover of Lisa Paige when
you watch that performance the FBI I'll
tell you I know so many people in the
FBO these are incredible people what
they have to what they're going through
watching this guy a total phony I mean
how about will stop it or something to
that effect said we will stop you yeah
well we'll stop him and then insurance
and he said originally I guess it was
the two of them no then he said the next
day well I meant the American people and
even the Democrats say that doesn't work
no he's a page contradicted him and gave
a more honest assessment
I heard she did much better than he did
and she was honest and took a lot of
hard shots but at least she was honest
about it he's a disgrace to our country
he's a disgrace to the
FBI a disgrace then how he's still being
paid is beyond belief
did you like president Putin's idea
Robert Muller should go talk to him this
I was I was fascinated by it so they
have a treaty where they work together
with the United States because everyone
said we don't have an extradition treaty
but they have a treaty where they work
together and his prosecutors would
prosecute it and he said that Robert
Muller's people could go with them but
they probably won't want to yeah
interesting
let me ask you do you think they're
going to want to go I don't think and of
course this pitbull Andrew Weissman who
I think I was a pretty atrocious record
that we have found very said what's
happening to our country because of this
we have would never done better in so
many ways including economically but
when you see this thing going on and I
will tell you it's driven a wedge
between US and Russia maybe we've just
knocked down that wedge but it has
driven a wedge and President Putin said
that one of the early things he said
when we started he said it's really a
shame because we could do so much good
whether it's humanitarian aid throughout
the Middle East whether it's not just
Syria so many different things the
safety of nuclear which is ultimately
there's nothing bigger and nothing more
important and they drove a phony we're
just a phony witch-hunt rigged deal with
guys like Peter struck and Comey and
McCain McCabe struck Paige the whole
group and you can imagine who else it's
a real it's a real shame and there was
Russia interference
Hillary paid through a law firm a
investigative group using GPS they hired
a foreign national that put together a
Russian dossier that was used to lie
about you which by the way Putin
confirmed today he didn't have such
information apparently he knew exactly
about it because he's been saying it
makes him angry when he sees it and you
know it's very interesting you look at
what's happening and you look at what
that whole thing he understood it and he
was I don't know if you could see it he
was incensed even talking about it but
he's willing to take those 12 people
there is no extradition but he's willing
to let Robert Mahler's people
over there and bring a big investigation
of those people working together with
Russian investigators last question
because I know you've got a lot to do
and you just finished a busy day you've
now been to 21 countries in since
January of 2017 like North Korea you
were very clear and saying that this is
a process would you like to be in a year
both with North Korea and with Russia
well I think we're doing really well
with Russia as of today I thought we
were doing horribly before today really
been horribly dangerously he's that big
that dramatic today oh I think it was
great today but I think it was really
bad
five hours ago I think we really had a
potential problem don't forget with two
nuclear nations 90 percent of the
nuclear power in the world between these
two nations and we've had a phony witch
hunt deal drive us apart this is the
biggest wedge this was the biggest it's
the thing that he told me when he went
in he said what a shame
he felt it was very hard for me to make
a deal because of you know all of this
nonsense and much of the games nonsense
you have to understand you take a look
and you look at all of these people I
mean some were hackers so then again are
they 14 people then they have 12 people
these aren't 12 people involved in the
campaign then you have many other people
some told allow you look at Flynn it's a
shame but the FBI didn't think it was
lying with Paul Manafort who's who
really is a nice man you look at what's
going on with him it's like Al Capone
2005 tax case or two cases I guess is
very up it's just a sad thing it's a
very sad thing for our country to see
this mr. president thank you so thank
you very much
thank you thank you very much appreciate
it